el sueño de 10 y está acá llama de
recorrer las ruinas de machu picchu se
cumplió
este turista japonés que permaneció
atrapado por la pandemia en perú durante
siete meses logró a conocer este paraje
ancestral con un permiso especial de las
autoridades y se convirtió en el primero
en visitarlo tras el levantamiento de
las restricciones por la emergencia
sanitaria tu sur este tour es realmente
asombroso gracias por dejarme ver esto
aunque la propagación del brote de kobe
19 impidió que usara el pase que había
comprado para entrar en marzo a la
ciudad inca nada pudo impedir que su
estadía en una localidad en las faldas
de las montañas cercanas a este antiguo
poblado andino terminará con su ascenso
al santuario que según cifras oficiales
fue visitado por más de un millón de
turistas internacionales en 2019 pero no
japonés ha ingresado junto con nuestro
jefe de parque el impacto de la pandemia
en territorio peruano afectó a decenas
de ciudadanos que como takayama no
pudieron retornar a sus lugares de
origen debido al cierre de fronteras en
la nación que tiene la mayor tasa de
mortalidad por cada 100.000 habitantes
de acuerdo con datos de la universidad
yo